[Music]
candace is with us she's in austin texas
hi candace how are you
i'm blessed steve how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
yeah i was just calling hoping to get
your opinion um you helped my husband
and i before we
got married to get out of debt um and
we've been out of debt for the last
oh five and a half
yeah
years
it's all thanks to you and your program
so
um but we're kind of at a sticky
situation we bought our home about four
and a half years ago
and
all of our extra money is aside from
retirement savings that we've been
putting into a mutual fund
and then we have some stocks and so
we've built up enough now that we could
go and pay off our mortgage
and we're just trying to decide if
that's the best move to make knowing
that
this is going to be a rental home
okay um
well let's go back to the part where you
said you've been following our process
and you use that to get out of debt
okay um
you mean you loosely generally know what
we teach or somehow you
had plugged into details of what we
teach
no i mean i definitely can
can plug in the details we have our um
so you know my answer to your question
then
i mean i think that we should pay it off
i mean what would i mean
have you ever heard me in any of our
teachings say anything else
no never one time that i tell people to
build up money into a mutual fund and in
single stocks to pay off their mortgage
i told them to just pay off their
mortgage
does that sound familiar
yeah no i mean we we put the money into
to mutual funds rather than just having
it in a savings account but
i understand um i understand what i'm
saying is
what i'm trying to understand is um
uh
i mean i think we inspired you to get
out of debt but you never really got
down into the details of exactly what we
teach in the baby steps and how to do it
because you wouldn't have done what
you've done if you understood that if
you were following our stuff which you
said
because we don't teach people to do what
you've done we teach them to pay off
their house
and so now that you've done it though
you've got the money yes i'd pay off
your house today
now then you've got a paid for house
wait a minute you said rental which
means you're going to sell that or
you're going to move to another house
and take out a mortgage
yes well we want to
our plan is to
then
buy
snowball money to buy a piece of land to
build our home on with cash
or are you going to take out a mortgage
to build your home
well you're going to take out a mortgage
to build it okay
i want you to have rental property again
you're welcome to do whatever you'd like
to do candice you're you're obviously an
adult you get to make your choices
you called and asked me what we would do
and what we teach okay so let's go back
baby step
four is fifteen percent of your income
going into retirement after you're out
of debt and have your emergency fund in
place does that sound familiar
yes okay and five is take care of kids
college and six is you put everything
else on the house until it's paid off
okay
then if you're going to buy other
properties you save and pay cash for
them if you can't you need to sell the
other house
so
i don't think you're going to follow
what i teach but i'll go ahead and tell
you what it is
because it's so different from your plan
but what we teach is and i'll tell you
why we teach it so you'll understand the
why too but um what we teach is i would
take all of the money that you've got
today and i'd pay off your house
i would pile up cash as high as i could
pile it up and if you're unable to
build the property on the piece of land
without borrowing money then i would
sell this other house in order to pay
cash for my residence because having
your residence paid off
and paid for or having a residence
mortgage with a pay with a paid off
rental property that makes no sense at
all
so what i would tell you to do is get
your residence paid off wherever that is
through whatever message or method we're
going to use here
and then i would start saving and pay
cash for my first rental but in no case
am i going to tell you to borrow any
more money in all of these scenarios so
if i woke up in your shoes
i would pay cash i would take the money
out and i would pay off your mortgage
today
then i would pile up more cash and when
i got ready to buy the land and build
the property i would sell the current
residence pay cash for your new place
with the saved money and the sale of
your current residence
and then you'd have a paid for nicer
place on acreage
now you've got no bills in the world
let's pile up cash and go buy a rental
somewhere
but i'm not going to try to back into
the rental now i don't think you're
going to do that but that's how i would
do it by the way that's how i
did it and it worked fabulously
but it requires a little more patience
on buying the rental you're trying to do
about six things at one time here you
want to have investments you want to
have a paid off house and you want to
have a paid off rental and you want to
build a house out in the country
on the land and so you've g you can't be
doing all these things at one time
you're building you it's going to catch
up with you
so the good news is you've saved some
money and you've got some options now
the only question is what you're going
to do
from this point forward and you've got
to make that decision i can't make that
for you thank you for the call
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you want to
know what the baby steps that we teach
are exactly and exactly how to follow
them in detail
that's what the best-selling book the
total money makeover is it's on sale for
ten dollars right now
people buy them by the case and give
them away as gifts
but in great detail
exactly how people have become baby
steps millionaires the shortest distance
between where you are and wealth is all
in the total money makeover